you should not be doing 80% of the work
that you're currently doing your
business 80% or more we all have the
same 24 hours in a day you me Bill Gates
Donald Trump we all have the same 24
hours the difference between the
successful entrepreneurs the one who
really make it the one who end up
changing a world and realizing their
dreams and the ones who don't quite make
it don't quite get there is how you
spend your time how you spend those 24
hours so today I'm going to share with
you five insanely productive habits of
successful entrepreneurs number one is
eliminate you need to eliminate a whole
bunch of the stuff that's on your plate
right now not give it to somebody else
not hand it off to some technology
eliminate it gone because it's not
adding value to your business and so
many entrepreneurs you're so in your
business you know running on that wheel
that it's hard to take out take a step
back and look and see is this really
actually adding value and this may be a
great exercise for you to do on your
vacation the next time you take a
vacation you come back and you think wow
that some of this work that I'm doing
just isn't working it's not helping I
want to challenge you for a second okay
I want you to think I want you to step
back and and say yeah I've heard this
before and I really want you to focus
okay stay with me for a couple minutes
focus here because you you right now
think that all the work that you're
doing is is high value has to get done
this has to get done in my business
where you really need to change that
mindset because if you have this big
goal right whatever goal you have for
your company for yourself personally how
are you making progress towards that
goal right now are you happy you say
yeah I'm hitting all my marks and
Momentum's out of control this is really
awesome if you're there that don't
change anything but if you're not then a
lot of the work that you're doing is not
working it's not working what you're
doing right now so you need to change
and a lot of that is eliminating I'll
give you a quick example yeah I run
mastermind groups we get together once a
month entrepreneurs come together and I
used to take notes of what everybody
said that we're going to do when
what we discussed in the meeting I would
share those notes afterwards right it's
common common business practice at board
meetings and business events that you
take notes and you share the minutes
after and it took a lot of work to write
the notes but also to compile it into
trying to read what my handwriting was
and and then send it off to everybody
and then one one month I was just too
busy you know I was too busy I had a
huge thing to the next day and then I
didn't send out the notes and I forgot
about it and then and then I realized oh
I didn't send the notes and nobody cared
nobody cared nobody wrote to me to say
hey Ivan were the notes and I stopped
doing it from then on and nobody asked
me about them and he or it was thinking
I was adding this high value thing to
them write provide lots of added to your
customers give them a great experience
go go or over deliver like crazy I
thought I was really helping them out
and they didn't care and I was doing
every single month multiple times a
month because I had multiple groups and
I stopped and it gave me time to work on
better things to my company so I need
you to really evaluate every single task
you're doing and is this working or not
because if it's not then you have to
have the courage to cut it out so number
one is eliminate number two is
automating now that you've eliminated
all the stuff that doesn't need to get
done there's still a lot of stuff that
has to get done but it doesn't all need
to be done by a person and it definitely
doesn't all need to be done by you you
need to look at ways to automate your
processes okay look at software look at
tools look at technology to take things
that you do repeatedly and make it more
automatic if I have to do something more
than two times I look for a way to
automate it
I brought a programmer on in staff to
basically handle a lot of the things
that I need to get done in my business
that I don't want to do anymore
that it frustrates me to have to do this
repeatedly and I know can be solved
through technology and so you may have
the knowledge to do that or you may need
to research or you may need to find
somebody to help you with that but a lot
of the tasks you're doing and that your
team are doing could totally be
automated and taken off your plate and
hey it's great because you know you
have more time for yourself but also
there's less mistakes that are made and
you know the computer doesn't take
vacation or sick days or personal time
off and you make sure everything gets
done properly for your business so first
eliminate and then look at what's left
and see how you can automate a lot of
the remaining tasks away
number three is delegating and this is a
huge problem for a lot of entrepreneurs
you have to give up control guys you
have to give up you cannot do this all
yourself you have to bring the right
people on yes but you have to be willing
to give up control hire people who are
better than you at those specific tasks
that you're hiring them for and let them
do their job
what do you add that's the highest value
to your business when you are walking to
your your office okay even if it's a
home office you're walking from the
bedroom to your home office wherever it
is you need to ask yourself this
question what's the highest value that I
can bring to my business today what is
the highest value I can bring to my
business today and then go do that and
not all the other stuff that stuff needs
to be delegated away so we've eliminated
all the stuff that's not adding value
we've automated as much as possible but
there's still some remaining tasks that
need to get done and need to get done by
a person but it doesn't mean it has to
be you you need to give up those tasks
to people who love doing that stuff are
way better than you and you can focus on
adding more value to your business the
challenge for a lot of entrepreneurs is
I said at the start you shouldn't be
doing 80 percent plus of the work you're
currently doing because that 20 percent
that's the gold that's what's really
going to help you build something big
that's what's really going to catapult
your company forward and you're spending
only 20% of your time on it now imagine
if you were spending a hundred percent
of your time on the high value eyewear
you can add the most impact your
business that's where you need to be
spending your time and the first person
you bring on you may be saying well I
don't have the budget I can't hire
somebody I'm not making any money it
doesn't have to be a full-time person
the first person I hired in my business
was for one hour a day and forget what I
paid him 12 15 bucks an hour for one
hour a day because that's all I could
afford
but that one hour gave me more than one
hour a day to go and do my stuff because
he was better
that I was and freed up my time and it
gives you practice in hiring people and
in managing people on a small scale
before you ramp up and grow so you have
guys you have to delegate things away
don't be in complete control all the
time and realize that you need to build
a team people to get your movement to
happen
number four is chunk this is a super
important rule that most people do not
take advantage of it's a hidden secret
of my productivity success okay anything
that you do multiple times per day do
once per day that things like check
email okay once per day because when you
are jumping between tasks the task the
task the task and you work on something
really important in somebody emails you
or calls you and you get interrupted you
are set back and you try to get back
into that task and it's over it takes
you another 40 minutes just to get back
into that task and good luck not getting
another email within those 40 minutes so
you're constantly just putting out fires
and being responsive mode instead of
proactively taking control over your
time and saying this is this is a chunk
that I am spending working on my
business
I prefer 90 minute chunks at a time with
15 minute breaks in between I find that
90 minutes is a great time to stay
focused your brain doesn't get tired you
have a lot of energy and then you have
15 minutes to break in between your main
chunks
okay so 90 minute chunks 50 minute
breaks anything that you doing multiple
times per day
you really want to per day anything
you're doing multiple times per week
you're doing once per week
anything you do multiple times per month
you're doing once per month so you know
I do these videos on a Wednesday and
instead of me the set-up time right and
send up my tripod and microphone I have
to think about what I'm going to say I
have to get in the zone you know I have
to may have to do a sample video just to
get the energy going right but once I'm
in the zone I get in the flow and I'm
creating awesome videos every time and
so it's great to have all that in the
chunk and not do one video today and
then one video the next day in one video
the next day because it breaks up the
flow I got to get all dressed up for you
guys you know I got a shave got to put
on the shirt but that applies to every
in your business so you know for me
Monday is my admin tasks day okay so
it's my in the business stuff so if I am
you know reviewing documents that my
team may have sent me or looking at a
pitch that a big brain wants to work
with me on or forming partnerships and
alliances it's kind of being the
business stuff that's still very
high-level I do all of that on Monday
and it sets me up for the week and get
all of my tasks done for the week on
Monday but you know what maybe I don't
shave or maybe I'm you know wearing
shorts or whatever like it doesn't
matter because I'm not meeting anybody
that day I'm all in the zone focus on
one thing introvert mode get in get
tasks done Tuesday now I'm doing my book
so Tuesday I'm in book writing mode and
again you know maybe I don't shave you
know maybe I go to Starbucks
whatever I'm in the zone and I can focus
the whole time on the book because
there's nothing worse and when you write
in the book to be interrupted to have to
deal with a crisis and then try to jump
back in your book and you totally forgot
where you were it takes me it takes me
off in an hour just to get in to my book
of where I was from the last time I
looked at it so that's a huge time
investment and you don't want to do that
to dental only have half an hour writing
where you want to be able to have a huge
chunk of the day so the whole day is
writing Wednesday I do video I talked
about it and again I get set up so now I
shape I have my shower I shave I'm in
the zone I'm thinking I'm gonna stay in
the shower you know now I'm more my
extroverted personality ready to answer
questions ready to inspire people and I
have my whole day of doing video
Thursday is my public-facing day so
Thursday I'm out doing meetings I'm
doing my radio show I'm doing interviews
I'm speaking out conferences you know
Thursday is that public-facing day and
again you know have my shower shave
ready to go extraverted day get those
partnerships working and it sets you up
because it's hard to switch it's hard to
switch between introverted writing that
book deep in thought - then extrovert
video ready to go
I find that challenging and if you're
just constantly jumping from one to the
other together together nothing's going
to be great it's all going to be okay
mediocre it's not going to be your best
work so you have to give yourself the
space in a time to focus chunk your time
and number five is
phones I hate interruptions I hate
unscheduled phone calls
I hate unscheduled meetings so no phones
isn't hey no phones at all in the
business but when there are phone calls
when there are meetings first of all for
me it's always on a Thursday that helps
save a lot of my time but second of all
I'm calling you I'm going to be on time
it's scheduled in our calendars jointly
or if we're doing a meeting usually
you're coming to me I have them all back
to back to back to back to back and you
need to you need to be on the phone you
need to have meetings as part of your
business for most people but it's the
unscheduled ones that are killer
it's the you're in the middle of working
on this big project of the big idea to
revolutionize your company and then
somebody calls you and interrupts your
flow right and again phone calls might
be important for your business and if
they are that's great but it doesn't
have to be you answering them right you
can eliminate most of them you can
automate them with voicemail and you can
delegate them to somebody else on your
team if it's really important guys your
time is important you have to free it up
to focus on the high value stuff you
should not be doing at least 80% of the
work that you are doing if you want to
have big success if you want to change
the world if you want to spark your
movement and influence a ton of people
and sell a ton of products and services
then it's going to come from you
spending your time on what you are best
in the world at and if you're spending
too much your time doing all that other
stuff how can you expect great results
it's not going to happen
you'll be mediocre at best so in summary
the five insanely productive habits of
successful entrepreneurs number one
eliminate number two automate number
three delegate number four chunk number
five no phones and believe those are
watching like the video you can
subscribe to the channel and see more
videos just like this thank you so much
for watching I'll see you soon
if you want more believe energy running
through your veins sign up for the
newsletter below it's free you're gonna
love it
hi I'm Jason Grif on Sica of roz
online.com and I want to say Evan
Carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and XD only newsletter I
prioritize and look forward to period